it is so ironic that the people who are
who are supporting federal agencies and
technocrats and bureaucrats in their
quest to undermine the will of the
american people would have the audacity
to call themselves true democrats if you
really believe that the majority of the
american people support joe biden who
most days doesn't seem to know what his
own name is you should welcome donald
trump being on the ballot in 2024
because you should be so confident that
the american people would reject him but
i think that the democrats do not think
that the american people would reject
trump i think the most democrats
understand that things were going much
better in this country under trump that
joe biden's approval ratings are some of
the lowest that we've ever seen for any
president ever the most recent gallup
poll numbers on joe biden's approval
rating are the lowest for any president
that they've ever recorded in their 70
plus year history and so why do they why
do they fear trump because they fear
american democracy it is in fact the
opposite of what you're describing